ايضا الان نعود الى مراسلنا عمر حوراني من
غازي عنتاب لربما لديه الجديد عمر في جهود
الاغاثه التي نزلت تستمر
نعم ما زالت عمليات محاوله انقاذ العالقين
تحت هذا المبنى مستمره كما تشاهدون هناك
عمليه ازاله الكتل الثقيله في من محيط هذا
المبنى لكي يتمكنوا من الاقتراب اكثر الى
منافذ قد تمكنهم من الوصول الى العائله
التي ما تزال عالقه في هذا المبنى اود
الحديث عن هذا المبنى هذا المبنى يقع وسط
مدينه غازي عنتاب في منطقه غازي مختار
باشا يتواجد في هذا المبنى حسب احصائيات
مبدئيه 24 شخصا تم انتشال حتى الان 20
شخصا وما زال اربع اشخاص عائله واحده ما
زالوا تحت انقاب هذا المنزل كما كنا خلال
الساعات الماضيه قد رسمنا عمليات انتشال
مستمره في هذا المنزل المتواجدين في هذا
المنزل قد يكونوا من اكثر
الناس حظا من بين المباني التي انهارت حيث
تم انتشال عشرين شخصا من بينهم سته عشر
شخصا هم على قيد
على قيد الحياه خلال الساعه الماضيه كنا
نرصد انتشال العائله الاخيره
وهي مكونه من ثلاثه اشخاص كانت لحظات
مؤثره جدا لحظات من الترقب كان العمل
بمعدات بسيطه ودقيقه جدا
نعم
نسمعك عمر
نعم اذا نعود ونتحدث ونعيد للساده
المشاهدين حديثنا عن هذا المبنى اذا ما
تزال العمليات
عمليات محاوله ما تزال محاولات انتشال
ضحايا من تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى مستمره كما
تشاهدون هناك عمليه عمليه ازاله الكتل
الاسمنتيه الثقيله من محيط هذا المبنى
ومحاوله الوصول الى الى
منافذ قد يصل منها الصوت لاشخاص عالقين هي
عائله مؤلفه من اربع اشخاص متواجدين تحت
انقاذ هذا المنزل اذا هذا المبنى تم
انتشال منه 20 شخصا 16 شخصا هم على قيد
الحياه ومن تبقى هم عائله واحده
من اربع اشخاص اذا تتم هذه العمليه وبعد
قليل كما جرت العاده وما كما تابعنا خلال
العمليات الماضيه يتم اطفاء المعدات
الثقيله ويتم دخول حاله الصمت حيث يطلب من
الجميع الصمت
يقوم رجال انقاذ بالنداء ومحاوله الاستماع
ان كان هناك اشخاص تحت انقاض هذا المنزل
ما زالوا على قيد الحياه ويسمع صوتهم بكل
الاحوال عمليات العمليات مستمره هذا
المبنى كان فريق الجزيره قد وصل اليه
بالدقائق الاولى لانهيار هذا المبنى وكنا
قد وصلنا بعد حدوث الزلزال بدقائق
واستمعنا لاصوات اشخاص كانوا تحت هذا
المبنى يطلبون المساعده وكانت هي لحظات
قاسيه ومؤثره لم نستطع حينها تقديم اي شيء
الا ان قمنا بايصال صوتهم ونقل هذه
المعاناه هذه الماساه المستمره لاناس تحت
الانقاب خلال الساعات الماضيه كان وضع
مؤثر جدا هنا يتواجد مئات مئات العائلات
منهم مئات الاشخاص هم في حاله ترقق قد
يكون هم من ذوي العائله المتبقيه من
المتعاطفين مع هذه العائله حاله انسانيه
عاليه عاليه نشهدها هنا من خلال ترقبهم
هذه هذه الوجوه التي تترقب بكل بكل
اخبارا طيبه لسماع اي اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
غازي عنتاب